nobody can't afford it hi my name is
Jojo okay
hi my name is Eric Andre from the Eric
Andre show and these are my favorite
videos so this first one is by H each T
it's called Goa Goa MPU this is one of
my favourite videos on the internet
[Music]
that's a German kind of rap
techno music video about a guy arguing
with a cop it's like 17 minutes long you
guys are cool Garfield share and a weird
Burning Man girlfriend that's oddly hot
am bu yeah it's so amazing next one is
called the we market Montgomery wrap
this is like one of the og first videos
ever saw on YouTube maybe pre-youtube
maybe like a bombs world and his hook is
his flea market is just like a mini mall
which may well suck so know why that's
the selling boy feel like this guy's
never listened to a rap song in his life
like his son is just really into rap and
he's like I couldn't make a rap song - I
got it get the cameras from the church I
know you talk about a flea market
it's a goddamn six-minute commercial
what's the fetus made of mercy whoa whoa
what makes you think that I want you
back this next one is by our AED ray
AIDS it's yeah it's called I know she
wants me back I don't think she wants
him back I think this woman has a
restraining order against this guy
because he's clearly emotionally
disturbed and he's wrapping terribly in
a concrete pit no she wants feedback
this guy is so painfully unmusical it is
so pleasurable to quote Bill Hicks I'm a
kid with a sore tooth I can't stop
touching it that's what it sounds like
as you're having a stroke so the next
video is John Kilduff s' let's eat drink
and paint TV I think no let's paint
exercise and blend drinks TV hey
everybody welcome back to the live
edition of let's paint exercise and
let's make blended drinks tonight and
we're taking your calls there's a guy at
a public access show we stretch too you
know before you do this you want to
stretch my biggest influence for the
Eric Andre show this video progresses
all these like ms-13 gangsters call add
like curse him out the entire time this
is the best video I'm actually friends
with this guy he's an artist I reached
out to him season 1 of the show he
actually did the Eric Andre show he
ended up cutting the bit because it was
trying to be this video
shake that thing going posh is one of my
favorite videos it's like the DNA of my
mind sorry what's wrong with this
machine okay next and last video
everybody knows this video it's a very
iconic YouTube video but it's still one
of my favorites well I woke up to go
give me a cold pop then I thought
somebody was barbecuing said Oh Lord
Jesus it's a fire some woman's name is
sweet brown I am in love with this woman
then I ran out I didn't grab no shoes
and none Jesus no shoes no nothing Jesus
if I ever have an audition where the
casting director is like you bring in
your monologue or your favorite scene I
just want to do this lady's speech I
didn't a smoke get me I got bronchitis
ain't nobody got time for that ain't
nobody got time for that
okay those are my favorite videos peace
a poor man seeking woman
- not just the Eric Andre show okay so
get used to that America we're gonna get
wet